are you excited for Star Wars
Battlefront 2 no I don't mean the first
Battlefront 2 from 2005 anyway one of
the developers has revealed some new
details about the Battlefront 2 that's
coming this year I'm met and this is
your scruffy looking Gamespot news
update associate design director Dennis
branville confirmed on Twitter that like
the first game Battlefront 2 will use
dedicated servers for multiplayer he
also said that while the sequel's new
class system won't offer the same level
of Freedom as the first game Star cards
you will be able to customize a class to
suit your play style and last but not
least he mentioned that developer dice
is working on some improvements to the
reload system which is going to be
somewhat of a combination between
cooldowns and traditional reloading
we'll keep you updated as more
information is revealed so make sure to
like And subscribe to be one of the
first to hear the juicy
details Star Wars Battlefront 2 Launches
on November 17th for PS4 Xbox One and PC
the sequel to 2015's Battlefront
introduces a single player campaign and
it's going to put players in the shoes
of an imperial Commander however at
times it will switch perspectives to
characters like Luke Skywalker and kylo
ren but hey if you can't wait until
November to shoot some Stormtroopers and
need more Star Wars right now then head
on over to our Gamespot Universe Channel
and watch our breakdown of The Last Jedi
trailer
[Music]